[Music]
so
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
does the biden foreign policy differ
from that of trump's
at this point not really however there
is one difference
trump challenged the bipartisan
consensus and failed
biden on the other hand appears happy to
oblige
the interagency consensus is winning
again
[Music]
crosstalking american foreign policy i'm
joined by my guest ivan elin in
washington
he is a senior fellow at the independent
institute and author of the book
war and the rogue presidency in del mar
we have scott ritter he is a former
intelligence officer
and a united nations weapons inspector
and in los
angeles we cross the joe collins he is a
former california congressional
republican candidate
and u.s navy veteran all right gentlemen
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want and i
always appreciate it let me go to scott
first in del mar
i want to go out for my um introduction
here we have a new president we have a
new administration
uh we were told that would be everything
different from trump but in terms of
foreign policy there's an enormous
amount of continuity
and i think it's very important to point
out too is that as i said
is that trump fought the bipartisan
consensus and he largely lost
but joe biden seems to be really quite
willing to embrace it i mean
we look at uh biden's policy towards
russia towards china
his administration is going to places
really fast i don't think they know
how they're getting there and what the
outcome is going to be because it's
terrifying a lot of people
how do you see this scott go ahead well
understand that the biden administration
was compelled to reconstitute
the mechanisms of national security
policy and foreign policy making
uh the the trump administration had um
gone rogue for no other term uh in in
terms of how policy was made
many positions were not staffed other
positions were just ignored
and you know trump and his inner circle
were making policy um as opposed to the
old-fashioned way where
um you know ideas were put out to
different
departments they came together in
deputies committees uh in the in
the national security council who came
together in principles committees where
the the cabinet members got together
and made uh you know gave the president
options
um that's what biden's returning to and
when you do that you become a prisoner
of process
and so that's what we see with uh you
know american foreign policy national
security policy today
is that uh joe biden has allowed the uh
bureaucracy
of decision making to once again
uh take over and and as a result we we
see a lot of confusion
we see a lot of crosstalk as they try
and get their act together i don't think
we have a mature foreign policy
uh and that was rel that was that was
evident
in the fact that biden released what he
called the interim national security
strategy
document normally this document takes
months to prepare
uh it is a finalized document that
provides
solid foundation upon which departments
and uh
and it can formulate policy this was
interim guidance it was gobbly goop and
it's it's indicative of the fact
that the byte administration is uh
spreading water they're struggling to
keep their head afloat
they really don't know what they're
doing well scott i mean but
you have this enormous amount of um what
i would say bombastic rhetoric without a
coherent policy let me go to ivan here
i mean going back to the um on the the
processes of
foreign policy making but what about the
policies themselves i understand they're
going back to the ways
of how to formulating it but it seems to
me that they're uh defaulting back on
uh policies that were not garnering uh
success
ivan i haven't even in washington go
ahead well you can
i think you can uh make that argument i
i would
say that biden is certainly more
conventional
than trump and he certainly has scott
put it he's going back to the
original bureaucratic model
but of course that uh allows the
agencies to
you know ossify the process and squelch
any new ideas now the problem with trump
on the other hand
was he himself i some of his policies
were very new and some of them were
actually acceptable but the problem that
he had was
he he just shot from the hip there were
there was nobody to
to uh to uh challenge him when he
he when he kind of went off the
reservation sometimes so i think you
know
there has to be sort of a happy medium
but i think uh
joe biden uh is more conventional
certainly
but i'm not sure that biden you know for
instance
i don't think biden is all that
enthusiastic about
these forever wars either now of course
he's
more cautious about getting out of them
that's one area that's different
and i think you saw
[Music]
vis-a-vis russia that biden quickly
wanted to renew the
problem the most important thing in u.s
security is
still the existential threat of uh
russian nuclear weapons and also for
russia american nuclear weapons
and so i think that that has been a um
one
positive aspect of uh
administration it was done quickly and
also
i i fully support that and i think it's
a very important thing now
you can argue that i i would have
criticized biden for trying to
be uh um opposed to both russia and
china at the same time that's not a
henry kissinger
yeah you're getting you're getting ahead
of me
with china to uh you're getting ahead of
me that's russia
of course you have to do the opposite
here you have to make up with russia
balance against china in this particular
case but i don't see
that's being a very uh smart policy okay
that's exactly where i wanted to go on
this program here let me go to joe and
los los angeles here i mean i find it
peculiar very
troubling um this bombastic rhetoric
against
russia and china simultaneously and
essentially talking you know putting out
these um statements in public you know
we're gonna do we will defend ukraine
and sovereignty we will
you know defend taiwan's uh sovereignty
i mean have they thought all of this
through here because
and from from the chinese perspective
and the russian perspective
these are fighting words okay and people
are preparing for it
it seems to me very very um uh
immature and and bombastic from the
outgoing
i mean there's not even an attempt to
reach out and try to negotiate okay
we have a new administration this is an
opportunity to do it it's just the
opposite of what we're seeing right now
go ahead joe
yeah i have to absolutely agree you know
when it comes to the obama
administration's foreign policy i think
it's one of the worst i've ever seen
in my entire life i think this is the
first time we had a president
who would send people in this place in
order to make deals i think you know we
can't forget
that you know joe biden is using the
americans as
a personal sus fund to give funds back
over
to uh different countries without taking
care of the united states
first but i think when it comes to
foreign policy you know i can't think of
one thing that the bite administration
has
done that is going to positively affect
the united states in the interest of the
united states globally
a very good point there uh scott what is
this with ukraine here i mean
what is driving this is it is it the the
uh jake sullivan's victorian newlands
and tony blinkens
is it the president of ukraine zlalinsky
i mean why is this such an imperative
thing right now you have all these phone
calls with nato officials
eu officials everyone's really wound up
here
what's going on here what is driving
this
what's driving this is uh russia's
asserting itself as not only a regional
player but a global player and
the fact that the united states never
forget
that you know biden is falling back on a
foundation
of ideological beliefs in the united
states ace of e russia
russia lost the cold war and we've never
forget
forgiven vladimir putin for trying to
rebuild russia in the aftermath
if you want to understand what's going
on in ukraine today you need to
understand
that the united states spent a decade uh
investing in a gentleman named boris
gelson
who was supposed to subordinate russia
to all things western all things united
states
and this failed it failed egregiously
and the people who promoted this
promoted the embrace of boris yeltsin
had to deal with the reality of vladimir
putin
under barack obama there was a reset
attempt but it wasn't a reset for
vladimir putin
it was a reset for dimitri medvedev
while putin was prime minister
it was hopes that by supporting
mid-vietnam we could push putin out of
power
and have russia return to the fold of
western dominance this didn't work so
what's happening in ukraine
is an extension of a policy that seeks
to undermine vladimir putin's russia
uh by empowering the near abroad we saw
that in georgia we see that ukraine
we see that within the former republics
in the baltic um
it's a policy that's out of control and
not in touch with reality
we're supporting one of the most corrupt
governments in the world we're
supporting a state
a nation that doesn't function properly
and
we're destabilizing an entire region all
out of spite for vladimir putin that's
all this
is a spite for vladimir putin yes i mean
foreign
that's not a foreign policy demonization
is not a foreign policy i mean let me go
back to what
to you in washington here what i find so
peculiar here
the all of the quote unquote help from
uh the obama administration to help
ukraine
you know the uh being part of the
overthrow of the legal government
in 2014 as a result
uh crimea left and then you have the
donbass that went into revolt
and now they want the same b team from
the obama team
to come and help ukraine some more i
mean they keep talking about its
sovereignty
but it's because of these people that
the sovereignty of ukraine has
changed and not obviously to the the
betterment of kiev i mean
why do they keep trying the same failed
policies go ahead in washington
well i think they were they were uh
essentially
put down this path by george w bush who
promised ukraine uh to get into nato
and i think you know you ukraine is very
important historically to russia
and i think there's a big lack of
empathy
uh in the united states for russia and i
agree
that vladimir putin has been excessively
demonized because then it becomes
uh difficult to work with him on certain
issues
as i mentioned did they did do that with
the strategic arms
uh treaty and that's very important i
think for
for the whole world but i think you know
this is this demonization
biden didn't start that you know he uh
it's been going on uh ever since 1999 i
think when putin took over and
for some of the reasons that have been
stated and i also think that you know
i i dare i say this uh spheres of
influence whether we like to talk about
it or not that's the way the world still
works great powers expect to have
security because they have enough power
to create a security buffer
and if you run an alliance like nato
right up to the border of russia
and also try to include a key
country like ukraine that has always
been very
special to russia you're going to get
pushback from
uh russia in crimea in the donbas etc
and so i think
some of these policies go way back all
right i have to jump in here besides
biden but also i have to jump in here i
have to jump in here we're gonna
we have to go to a short we have to go
to a short break and after that short
break we'll continue our discussion on
american foreign policy stay with rt
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
remind you we're discussing u.s
foreign policy
[Music]
okay let's go back to los angeles uh joe
we had the
um the meeting in anchorage a few weeks
ago uh with china on american soil
and um um secretary of state um lincoln
got a real dressing down
and we had uh i think a week before that
the high commissioner for the uh
the eu was in moscow and he got a
dressing down from the foreign minister
lavrov here
i mean what's going on here i think
scott kind of alluded to it in the first
part of the program
um major countries push back because
they have
the resources to do it and it looks like
the biden administration
and the the atlanticist in general have
been
caught off guard but when when people
push back it's called aggression
okay from the other side of the fence
and saying we're asserting our interests
here
it we get this impression from
administration after administration that
no other country has interests you're
not allowed to have interest and if you
express it
it's called aggression and and that's
not how diplomacy works and we were told
by joe
that there would be diplomacy under his
administration i don't see any of it
anywhere right now go ahead joe in los
angeles yeah i think you're i think
you're right you know joe biden made a
lot of promises throughout his uh
throughout his campaign
but what we're seeing right now is a
bunch of nations who
are no longer afraid of the united
states i think they've lost all respect
for united states and i think one of the
biggest reasons why
is because um dubai has always been soft
on countries like china
but tried to press aggression towards
countries like russia
i think that you know we have a lot of
age politicians who are
sitting in a post uh cold war era and
they're still trying to enforce those
saints policies
we're at a time where you know the
united states need to lead by example
and not trying to force example upon
other countries so when you see other
countries taking their interest
in uh and in poorer countries with
smaller
uh economic uh development you know this
becomes a huge problem for the united
states
um like i said i think it's time for us
to be able to lead by example
instead of lead by force in our american
interest on other countries
you know scott what one of the i think
the at the core the problem
of all of this is here is that you know
the blinkins of this world they still
believe
for some strange reason maybe they watch
too much cnn
is that the the unipolar moment is still
with us well that has
is long long gone and countries like
russia and china
see the world as it is it's it's
multi-polar
and this is why we keep bumping into
heads here is that
there's different perceptions of how the
world order is and
is evolving here what do you say go
ahead scott
absolutely look uh you know the united
states missed uh historic opportunity in
uh 1991 1992
um in the immediate aftermath of the
collapse of the soviet union the end of
the cold war
uh you know george herbert walker bush
spoke of you know a new world order
where the united states would not
subordinate say it
would not subordinate itself to the
world but would work together
with the world through the united
nations to create
you know something that was different
from the bipolar existence
that was uh that existed during the cold
war
but the united states was unwilling i
would say unable
to rid itself of the mantle of a sole
remaining superpower and so the decade
of the 1990s
was wasted opportunity then came 911 in
the united states spent the next 20
years bleeding itself to death morally
and fiscally uh through this global war
on terror
we forgot about europe we forgot about
uh asia then donald trump came along
and freed us from you know what this
this
rules-based international order that
everybody speaks of uh he said no this
is america only america goes alone
now biden's trying to bring it back but
you can't undo history
the world has moved on it is not a
unipolar world
it's not even a bipolar world it is a
multi-polar world
and the united states is totally out of
step and we lack
any of the tools we lack the economic
tools we lack the military tools
we lack the diplomatic pools to deal
with this new reality and so we're just
floundering and i think that's what
we're seeing with the bible
administration
is american policy floundering because
we think we're dealing with you know
playing off one
rule book one game play the world's
playing off a different rule book a
different game play and we
therefore what we want it does not mesh
with what the world desires
you know i mean you know i really like
what scott had to say because it's so
appropriate
um but what is it going to take to
change that mindset
is it going to have to take um a major
conflict
where um the i mean let's look at you
know over the last
since the end of the cold war the united
states has just punched down
on on countries that could not defend
themselves very well
now they want to take on china and
russia simultaneously
i mean you need a different mindset
because all it does is lead to
catastrophe
and it's obvious for anyone watching
what's going on in the world here
but i look at the state department uh
news
releases i mean again they're they're
living in 1992
go ahead ivan yes i think that to some
extent that's true i think the us
uh has to accept uh other countries
having uh influence in their regions if
you want to call that a sphere of
influence or what do you want whatever
you want to call it to
dress it up with a more modern term i
think the political reality is
the us still has a pretty good lead in
military
force but of course china uh is gaining
and so is russia
and so uh economically china is gaining
rapidly so
you're right there are other centers of
power there's also european uh germany
and uh these these countries that are
economically
uh uh viable japan etc india
uh and so it is a multi-polar world and
the united states is going to have to
recognize that now of course
other empires like the british empire
they didn't
they they still in france as well they
still have
uh colonial mentality so i think it's
going to take a while to be disabused of
that for the us
and uh hopefully it's not going to be
there's not going to be a conflict with
russia or china
because they both have nuclear weapons
and i think that's the major constraint
on anything like that but certainly
there can be lots of
uh opportunities for mistakes or
miscalculations
and you know you have the old problem of
the
rising power yeah uh uh conflicting with
the status quo power and that uh
you know in 16 cases since 1500
wars break broken out uh you know in 12
out of the 16 cases now nuclear weapons
makes it
a different story now as does
the vast oceans that separate the united
states from both russia and china
at least the european part of russia
from the united states so
i do have some hope that some of these
geopolitical factors and geostrategic
factors
uh the realism will kick in
at some point and i think biden at least
as
as he's an experienced foreign policy
hand but on the other hand as we've been
saying
that can be a quagmire being captive to
uh you know old thinking uh
and the bureaucracies and that's what
he's gonna have to fight trump had to
fight the opposite
that he was he didn't really follow any
of that and
sometimes he got himself into trouble by
uh just going go doing whatever you
wanted so
you know it's one there's advantages and
disadvantages to both
approach but i think the united states
really needs to
pay attention to that the world has
changed and it needs to
uh you know get rid of some of these
alliances i i'm pretty radical on that
point i think they're
outdated and uh you know they can drag
us into wars that we don't want to be in
both in east asia
and in europe absolutely you've been on
many times on crosstalk and you and i
completely agree on that point here joe
one of the things that's happening and
it's something that
again part of the bipartisan consensus
they won't really say it out loud but
what they're doing is they want to
create a global nato
okay i mean it's really amazing how you
know these nato officials say
china is an opportunity for nato i mean
they actually
say that kind of stuff here because
they're looking for a mission
and what they what they can do is what
they want to do
is they really want to create a global
nato because then they don't need the
united nations they
are um the uh the legitimate power
deciders in the world here and instead
of learning from past mistakes because
nato should be dismantled completely it
should have been a long time ago what
they want to do is expand it
and they're the major targets russia and
china go ahead joe
yeah i think the global nato concept is
a is a
is a far statement i don't think that's
something that's ever going to happen i
think that we have to look at a new way
of being able to expand our reach to
other countries and i think that's
through investment the same thing that
china is doing
the united states should have been doing
a very long time ago instead we've been
we've been putting
pushing uh aggression um towards other
countries i think more of an investment
uh type of opportunity to be able to
expand our reach in in certain countries
has absolutely helped the united states
when it comes to uh foreign policy when
it comes to global policy as well those
are those are just my thoughts i think
it's time for us to
turn away from the aggression start
looking at more diplomatic ways to
expand united states interests in
different countries
you know scott we're rapidly running out
of time here one of the things that
it's really curious i mean that all of
this and it has bled from
the russia gate hoax this uh antipathy
towards russia
but if we you know look at nordstrom 2 i
mean
what the biden administration is doing a
continuation from the trump one
is willing to punish russia and germany
a nato ally
all at the same time and you know and
and you know
kind of uh thinking about what joe just
said here i mean yeah i think trade is a
good thing that
tends to cut down on conflict here but
what what about when you dictate
to your partners who your other trading
partners can be
i mean that that is such a chauvinistic
way of dealing with your foreign policy
nato is very important germany is very
important but you have to have the
energy policy that we decide in
washington and what is not decided in
europe it is really
ridiculous go ahead scott first of all
it's not about energy policy because
if you if you take a look at what
nordstream 2 does
it actually brings stability to europe
it provides cheap gas to uh
to germany which then can disseminate it
throughout europe and it
links russia's long-term economic
viability
to european stability russia would get
to play the gas weapon
one time one time russia would turn off
the gas to europe and that would be the
last time they sold any gas to europe
that would destroy the russian economy
so this is ludicrous for the united
states to uh
to to play this game this is about
american domestic politics
that's what all russia policy is it's
not about real geopolitics it's not
about
you know a global real politics it's
about american domestic politics where
we have demonized russia
we have feminized vladimir putin and now
our political leaders don't have
the intellectual curiosity or the moral
courage
to stand up and say hey enough of this
let's deal with the world as it is
not as as we pretended to be in
washington dc
well ivan one of the things that i where
i worried about
during this russia gate hoax is that it
would bleed into policy
and it has done exactly that okay
and that that is very destabilizing and
every everyone on this side of the pawn
is reading and
listening to what the western leaders
are saying about this and they're
preparing
and for good reason here i'm sorry guys
we've run out of time many thanks to my
guests in washington del mar and in
lawson
los angeles and thanks to our viewers
for watching us here at rt see you next
time
remember crosstalk rules